which merry berry you know we're really
starting choose you with whom you reeleezee
in the united states and increasing your
own the world de
your point of view and access of the
global pandemic for many people it
already feels like it is about statistics
lily medically
this is caring closer and closer to being
over and who
new who suspected who she the i was
written in the trap
yes the societal and cultural and the
pandemic would likely come before woaw
i already dead medical and the [ __ ]
mama bake your
types baseline risk of  death from
being in the worlds globally we hereafter
area and many countries were very far
from na blitzstart with week in cedar is
going well and then will talk about the
things de vertilde question mark's
kronen fires case in the united states
arno down nine die five percent  of my
peak of 215 5000 nu case is per day in
january
don diego 13,000 cases where they
unfortunately wie er things en spikes a
man on vaccinated people and join the
ta  lk about a momentarily
chakra the people who reaction humble
still getting the wires
memoranda things big bore a nine die
5% the small everywhere it's great start
in a warm bath ass
with jets jersey the numbers come down a
relatively quickly punching kan dat peaks
in  january
roon core i5 hundreds d and then down
to go 3fifty
idea that's the small and remodel nine
that person in terms of daily buy jets
for comparison
picasa can fascinate he fell
the nas any risks rest for
never gonna give us your ass like  this
and hedgerows the issue is when we
baked baseline resk in a huge
lucy's and in the united states the city
have reach out our other than people
who producer and twitter really bad
lucy's and
and 215 people who deeper into an address
lucy's and between 100 and
food expert they were no lift 315 buy
jets per these were not end hobby my
god baseline that grand resk
farmer getting closer and closer to do is
harder and the world the number  s there
also looking better and better
global cases of down' fifty five percent
of the peak and lampo hubert 103,000 new
purchase in cases where they were then
more then have to buy 317 5000 cases
product set long white go but more then
have reduced and global des  ardennes
built for that person
global daily dutch peaked over
january 14,000
almost peak derek en in early pro down
down to go
nine thousands german dave van
cobit globally silent jaya number of declining
more and more
nou in moma we ever had what budget
case is a  man of work people
for i get it up
the new show floating around is there
or the delta various regions floating
around and tomorrow will be joined by
doctor shishya' van brown university en
wiebelt hakte him about the delta works
is sometimes a number of other issues
what is the deal with the delta works and so is
the delta varian in this lake
transmission bal mori mori cases in many
countries are coming from the delta works
and z  o find wivine in the angry cases er
goin down nice morgen cases were saying
of the delta works in viewer foil
vaccinated you really do have my story
je outside special if you're in a highly
vaccinated there a bug lecture so de
chair of the your css  de per minute
madison have i am twitter criminal record so
again here also quote arno everybody's
i buy quite a few three-dimensional in chad
sorry with the delta marina forces back to
the chess board the eurocodes turns
eefje foil most often proteins u become
a special if you in a  highly box trees
and i jona jackson eat it
idea peace maybe just humming freight
white leds wheat the things you know but
the current situation there any
information about the delta aka in die en
barrier dermolin bad website suggest you
and who wants the color us if you  wish you
good crisis
hospitalization dutch er vol in fast
largely due to their families goodbye
in san francisco were the words with 17
percent overdose over reach 12 oil
vaccinat  ed mother buy nearly any posts
swirled his doctors and so
everybody's opening up and cooling
on tuesday to the california that's fine
porno
saddle i have of the us age over twelve
romanian and saw cut and insert and
always mostly southern and ride the
leaning
is hard horns der  discovered and e30
der and small number vaccinated people
will greatly infections model girl i get
where i seek and will almost never die
opkoop it so quiet
yunomi got the balance the people who
never wanna take any percussion and
there were many of them and for a long
time
the formulas minutes with the doom and
gloom earth how we are silent
dogo open nothing work from home only
new kids in school at night every where
everything is dangerous beacon never
ever ever take all corners of my card
balance en de belgische en balancing act
is the see you often
work really well against other areas
including the delta variant is je foil
vaccinated meaning directors at number
of days the hunger late  te box water
it two boxes there was and who bolster
that safety
by pieter on people who vaccinated there is
still in the 7th century that per se
vaccinated range for those who else but
your risk
fair and i variant is kon peter
medically lower than if you  were in a
place where only for the five for the
force and the population is nothing no this is
merely a and so as if this is mostly
common sense
tomorrow we will speak the doctor and
she's a more specifically bad de
variance
en hold in their production and
efficacy numbers
but it shows that although the big
picture is looking better and better
cases arising get some money en
vaccinated
let's talk about that next for the lang
is time out with having trouble finding
snacks dat ar selfie but actually taste
great and film japanese rs5
craving  and that's why it's great de
reis stumbled upon my [ __ ] and wisdom to
be on our sponsors
monkey ronald and c bars of delicious
snacks there long have grammys every
lesson about those two  drie grams of net cards
and just a higher than fifty galleries
perfect for aikido
hello car diet for any body bulaggi
jesper first i do love you like a love
de monkey do not and see bars
because it really dus de gray balances
white salty soft and chewie
polydaun eyes crunch of the net
sensient flavors color the caramel and caramel
je tony sisal sisal dark chocolate and
peanut butter dark chocolate and i've
ever will give you all of you money back
of your lover
dead man grab you can the link is down
below  and dokadi 20% off any other
projects for us coupon code pacman